that takes f5 for g1 is coming knight h6  is coming  queen g4 is coming  the good news for others is only three  moves to the time control  five seconds  okay who can spot the mate first g1  looks  g1 king f8 queen h6  king f7 richie seven  wow  i mean there's plenty of  choice at this point i think  sorry resigns  he resigns i'm over here machine though  he resides  okay  we have a leader it's another big game  three out of four  [Music]  wow  great game as well  very impressive  he got surprised in the opening but  reacted nicely  confidently king b1 knight bc1 f6  and alireza  at yeah one of the first critical  moments  he seemed like he just went astray or  moved 20 already with this bishop takes  f1